hey guys this is Cameron with motion
science and today I want to talk very
quickly about compositing specifically
fog compositing and what do I mean by
that well let me show you right here in
my timeline I've got a piece of stock
footage that I pulled off the web and
above that I have a piece of stock
footage of fog or smoke and smokes
moving upward typically what I see
happen is the motion designer will come
in to the smoke layer or fog layer and
go from normal to screen and boom you've
got fog over the top of your footage
well this isn't so true to life because
as you can see when I turned it to
screen the fog lightened up the scene
that's not how fog is displayed visually
so the proper way to composite fog is
very simple all we have to do is keep
our fog on normal go to effect channel
shift channels right here where it says
take alpha from alpha we change this to
luminance that's gonna take all of the
black values from the footage and make
those transparent as you can see right
here so without the effect here's the
black areas turn it on and boom it's
transparent well it's getting close but
it's still not quite there all we have
to do is go back to effect generate fill
and I'm going to tent this fog to match
the color in the scene so all I have to
do is just turn this off color pick
something maybe about there turn the
layer on and turn the fill layer on and
there we go
let me do a quick preview so there you
can see our composited fog in the scene
and just to show you the difference
this is the compositive fog if i
duplicate this layer turn off the
effects and sets a screen like most
people do that's what the screen mode
looks like and here's where ours looks
like so toggle between them screen mode
composited fog so really quick video
this week hope you learn something new
until next time I'm Cameron and this is
motion science